I am delighted to be with a group of
people
interested in entrepreneurialism in its
kind of broadest manifestation I have
spent my whole career in the nonprofit
sector and so hi I'm going to talk to
you about what I think of as the
application of being an entrepreneur in
in a non-profit setting and it's not
easy as Tom said I was at the Nature
Conservancy as president for almost
almost eight years prior to that I was
working with the Nature Conservancy in
California for 16 years so I spent most
of my career in the nonprofit sector at
more or less typical NGO typical the
sense that it's dependent on private
contributions carries out a very focused
mission and employs people who have a
deep passionate interest in that mission
and and have an alignment around that I
went to the Gordon and Betty Moore
Foundation in 2008 very beginning of
2008-10 and after having spent almost 30
years trying to raise money going to
foundation that has six billion dollars
in assets it was sort of like getting
into the vault and I I joked with people
the first day I was there so could
actually go look at the money I mean is
he's got piled up somewhere and but it
it's it's a sort of commonplace outlook
in the NGO community that nothing could
be easier than working at a foundation
is very hard to raise money and how hard
could it be to give money away there's
some truth in that but I'm going to
share with you a lot of the lessons I
learned about the difficulty of giving
money away although I will share with
you an insight I had when I started
there because again coming from an
organization with a 500 million dollar
operating budget at the Nature
Conservancy and then a need to raise
at least that much in capital
contributions every year because as many
of you may know the nature conservancy
buys land my biggest challenge the thing
that really kept me anxious was reading
that money in every year raising enough
money and any nonprofit leader will tell
you that just like it's just every year
you're just fixated on getting enough
money in so when I started the
foundation and asked folks like what's
the wood what causes anxiety here what
do you kind of wipe really get worried
about response was oh man at the end of
the year we've got hit are five percent
payout that's not easy so what you're
telling me is you worry about getting
money out the door yeah that's
unbelievable that was a mindset that I
hadn't anticipated and actually was an
insight into some of the challenges
frankly of of running a big foundation
so I'm going to share perspectives from
both of those roles and some things are
very similar and some things are very
distinct but I'd say overall managing a
big enterprise in the not-for-profit
sector and the for-profit sector in the
government sector has a lot of
similarities and I believe that one of
the most important characteristics of
leadership in the nonprofit sector is
one of entrepreneurialism and I'll and
I'll explain what I mean by that one of
the biggest challenges in the nonprofit
world is understanding how well you're
doing on a for-profit there are
conventions consistently applied
universally understood often legally
required that enable leadership or
anybody in a large enterprise or smaller
price for that matter to know how well
they're doing and typically those are
financial metrics
and a nonprofit organization don't have
any consistency in the metrics to
determine success or progress towards a
mission and frankly one of the biggest
shortcomings of nonprofit organizations
is that they begin to think of success
in terms of tactics and activities not
in results I have an almost obsessive
focus on outcomes and I always have i
remember when i started at the Nature
Conservancy which again has been
characterized by its I think very
successful tactic of buying land I
started there's a lawyer and
transactions were always in the pipeline
negotiated by very able field
representatives typically who had a
business degree I started in nineteen
seventy seven is fourteen years old just
I was really just more or less out of
law school but all these transactions
each one of which was a very fine
consequence in its own right I couldn't
see how does it add up how is this
individual transaction contributing to
some larger outcome and in as much as
the mission of the Nature Conservancy is
to preserve in essence this is a little
bit of a simplification the diversity of
life on Earth if seems like it'd be a
lot of transactions to get enough
diversity of life on Earth to satisfy
our mission so I'd say we don't in any
Enterprise that you go into large or
small if your eye on the ball what is
this enterprise all about what do I want
to accomplish and if I'm in a leadership
role or if I'm in an entrepreneurial
role what is my compass head towards
what am I trying to get done and it's so
easy any of you have worked in any kind
of enterprise realized day-to-day the
noise can distract you
and you lose sight and I see that a lot
in nonprofit organization how many of
you have worked for a non-profit even as
a volunteer a lot of you okay so that
means I can't lie to much about Lana
brotherman catch me on that but I think
you'd agree anybody who's working a
non-profit that keeping your eye on the
prize is a challenge again because in
part it's hard to define what that prize
is in ways that are simple
understandable and measurable another
challenge for nonprofit organizations is
the candidly the culture typically is
one of consensus and in part I think
that's attributable to the ethos the
mindset of like okay I have devoted my
life to a cause to a mission that is
sort of sanctified by the nonprofit
status bestowed by the government on
this enterprise and consciously or
unconsciously people in a nonprofit
organization I think feel they're a
little special because they've
sacrificed to go work for a non-profit
in a cause the cause driven and that is
a very admirable characteristic and it
is quite true people who work in
nonprofit organizations obviously are
there for the cause and nonprofits
typically don't pay as well as a
for-profit if you could benchmark and so
almost unavoidably or at least I'd say
understandably a culture of a non-profit
very much is like we're all in this
together and therefore I want to make
sure i get to touch every decision and I
want to make sure that i'm okay with
every decision and if I'm not okay with
the decision I sort of feel a sense of
embassy and like not aligning with that
my father started and through his whole
life ran a very successful business
engineering engineering business a
matter of fact got his degree at Cal my
father was a great small business leader
at that time in the 50s and 60s but he
very much had the outlook like this is
my business my capital in this business
I get to make the decisions and he was
not autocratic but he didn't tolerate a
lot of well you know I don't think I
align with it is likely get you on the
bus or you're off the bus so nonprofit
organizations are challenged by that
kind of culture and I don't say that
dismissively or derisive Lee it's just
the reality so being an entrepreneur in
that culture can be a bit of a challenge
candidly I look back on my now 35 year
career the nonprofit not-for-profit
sector thing you know I'm not sure I
really had the patience over all those
years to deal with that sort of culture
and I've made a lot of mistakes because
of that if you can't fight that you've
got to work with that speed in
nonprofits therefore is kind of rare and
today when we live in the VUCA world do
you see it you're familiar with that
comes out of the military there's a
enterprise near by the institute for the
future Bob Johansen has done a lot of
forecasting there he uses that term to
describe a volatile uncertain chaotic
ambiguous world getting more so and
what's interesting to me is many
respects Moore's law I'm going to put
you on this but anybody not familiar
with Moore's law because I'm embarrassed
to say so so Gordon Moore
founder of Intel in 1965 wrote a paper
in a now long gone professional journal
that described his projection of how
fast the speed of micro processes would
would would Excel would grow over time
and how the cost would come down and was
as these were exponential curves in 1965
1965 nine 1965 I was in eighth grade I
mean we were still using slide rules
Gordon projected that in 25 years
virtually everybody could afford what in
essence is a laptop computer a personal
phone and a number of other things that
would come as a result of the
application of his law the extraordinary
thing is not only did it last for the
period of time that he projected it's
still happening and interestingly
Moore's law has now become sort of
popularized to generically describe the
pace of change in society yeah so when I
came to the foundation of this is great
you know I mean Moore's Law we ought to
be able to think maybe there's more
second law how it would apply to the
philanthropic sector the not-for-profit
sector could we move with speed it's
really challenging so an entrepreneur in
the not-for-profit field has to deal
with the paradox of the world moving at
a very fast pace dealing with people who
are devoted to a car they believe in it
passionately it's like oozes out of
their their their pores and yet kind of
stuck in a very consensus oriented
mindset now having said all that I
continue to believe very very
unequivocally that the not-for-profit
sector and I would say you
more so the philanthropic sector is in a
position to drive major social change
more so than any other sector in society
but I don't see it stepping up to that
just yet now why do I say it can and why
do I say that it's not yet it can and
I'm going to talk about the foundation
community to our foundation has six
billion dollars in assets by law we are
required to give out five percent of our
asset wealth every year we can give more
but by law we're parting about at least
five percent so that's Stanford students
five percent a six billion is 300
million dollars every year so we turn a
spigot on every year and three hundred
million dollars comes gushing out and we
can do anything we want with that as
long as it's devoted to a philanthropic
enterprise unbelievable and I am that
connects tonight we could burn it and
next year i turn the spigot on another
three hundred million dollars comes out
so we think wow if if that's the case I
can burn that and I still have three
hundred million dollars and if I want
legally I could go into the six billion
dollars and use that why don't we shoot
for the moon only a foundation or only
will say private charity as the
wherewithal and actually the legal
ability to think about lasting forever
so we're set up in perpetuity I mean
maybe the Catholic Church is the only
other things like they can think in
perpetuity you know so usually wow
that's incredible we can last in
perpetuity ever with three hundred
million dollars coming out in today's
valuation every year to do something
great why wouldn't we reach for the
stars interestingly and i would say
quite candidly I think found aces are
among the most conservative actors in
society
and why is that I would assert because
frankly not enough people with
entrepreneurial zeal a passion for
moving fast for experimentation for
rapid prototyping for taking risks and
being willing to learn from it not
enough of those kind of people are going
to work for foundations it would be a
hugely contributory the contribution to
site if all of you with your
entrepreneurial backgrounds went to work
for induction you could change the world
and I don't mean to cast aspersion on
the people who work in foundations but
typically foundations have hired people
from academia or from NGOs and wonderful
people the people who work at our
foundation are fantastic people our
foundation was built on Gordon Moore's
belief that philanthropy should have a
strong business orientation to it
meaning keep your eye on the ball take
risks look he build Intel reach for the
fences that's Gordon's phrase reach for
the fences we're the biggest funder of
Environmental Conservation which is why
I came to the Foundation which is why I
knew the foundation biggest funder of
Environmental Conservation Gordon said
the inception of the foundation he wants
to win in the environment rather than
lose slowly I love that so here's a
extraordinary generous man comes out of
a business background says okay I want
to do philanthropy but I wanted to be
imbued with the best principles of a
entrepreneurial enterprise and in that
combination would be I believe the key
to solving or at least addressing major
social problems as I also think that
today's social problems we don't solve
them they're so complex you know we're
going to manage them so Foundation has
the capability of staying with a really
wicked problem for a very long time
trying things learning adjusting course
correcting learning adapting in real
time and it has the ability to strike
something really fast when I was at the
Nature Conservancy if an opportunity
came along that required significant
funding 10 20 million dollars and I'd
have to go raise that money and a lot of
times the opportunity if it was
something was like presented if we could
do this with that with the World Bank we
could drive a change that would
completely reorient say the the lending
policy of the World Bank but you need
some fast mover money out there that was
on the table to drive a slower bigger
international institution God you know
Kate ngak that couldn't do that at the
Nature Conservancy the foundation I can
call up our investment officer nothing
prevents me from saying Denise would you
wire 20 million dollars to this
qualifying non-profit yet our foundation
like many has encumbered itself with
processes to move money out and I have
to tell you is anybody here from the
Moore Foundation they could will be they
may be watching us on the futures
I say this was the greatest respect and
we develop processes to move money out
the door and they become an orthodox an
orthodoxy oh wow gosh you know takes six
money months to get money out the door
gotta fill out these forms we got
templates have to be reviewed by lawyers
all imposed on ourselves and it's hard
to strip those things out you think
about it foundations have no incentive
to change there are no external
influences that drive a for-profit to
respond to changes in customer tastes or
demand supply chain perturbations no
external influences that drive a
nonprofit organization to think about
how its soliciting recruiting support
and none of the external influences in
the firm save of legislature that a
government agency has to deal with to
make sure they get an appropriation
every year no external drivers that
impose that sense of urgency and a need
to change I was talking with a
consultant not long ago who is very well
known for his engagement with big
business actually in driving strategy
very fast in a rapidly changing external
environment and I've heard him speak and
I admire him enormous I've read his
books and I said yeah I'd love to have
you come help me think about how I could
position our foundation not as a grant
maker foundation think they make grants
is like this grant making machine but as
a change maker and using all the assets
of our enterprise that are named the
connections we have the ability to move
fast the ability stay with things for a
long time I'd love to have you help me
position this foundation is like a a
whole new concept of philanthropy you
said you know I worked with foundations
and I'm not going to do it anymore
because
they don't want to change so when I go
to when i go to work with a CEO at a
company large or small i asked them what
are the three maybe five things that you
worry about in the next five years that
can really disrupt your business and
they start there and then they work off
of that and start thinking about okay
looking ahead to have foresight to come
back to incite so they can take action
he said foundations like I asked them
what they're worried about needs like
job security its internal things that
they're concerned about so we're at a
point in society in this country when
philanthropic dollars are increasing at
a pace they never have before we will
see more money devoted to philanthropy
in the next 10 to 15 years than we've
seen in the last hundred Bill Gates and
Warren Buffett put a challenge out you
may have heard of called The Giving
Pledge and they asked people of net
worth of a billion dollars or more to
make a public pledge that they would
give away half of their wealth during
their lifetime and there are upwards of
a hundred people who have signed up for
that a fair number of them in this
community here you may have seen that
Mark Zuckerberg gave five hundred
million dollars of facebook stock to the
Silicon Valley Community Foundation
recently and these are just examples the
amount of money going into either
structured or directed philanthropy is
increasing dramatically so the
opportunity for that funding to take on
major social problems and drive major
change and be a leader is more right
than ever before and we are beginning to
see some very interesting shifts in how
the new philanthropists think many again
from this area so you may have heard
terms like strategic philanthropy or
venture philanthropy outcome-based
philanthropy but philanthropists
thinking in terms of the eye on the
prize how am I going to measure is
voltz how can I move fast how can I
rapid prototype how can I learn fast how
can I fail fast how can I take what I as
an entrepreneur have turned into
something very successful in a private
sector into the public sector and so I
think we're as I say at the threshold of
a kind of a renaissance rethinking of
reimagining of how philanthropy can work
and at the same time we're seeing more
nonprofit organizations that rely on
that support realizing that the the
characteristics attributes assets of
those who are successful in enterprise
management are imperative in the
not-for-profit world not-for-profit
world again has many people are drawn to
they have the cause deep in their gut
nonprofit leaders are often charismatic
Oh dangerously so sometimes as we've
seen able to attract people to them and
raise money but not so good at making
sure that that money is applied in a way
that really driving results but we're
starting to see more of that and more
business schools are seeing the
expansion of what's called social
enterprise in the business schools and
after all think about the future
business schools I'm convinced in some
days they want some day they won't be
called business schools because maybe
enterprise schools because the
distinction between nonprofit
organizations and for-profit
organizations is going to blur and I
actually think that the not-for-profit
sector could benefit enormously as I
said previously from having people come
in with really good leadership skills
and all their dimensions but also great
management skills keeping their eye on
the prize measuring whether they're
making progress and being willing to
adapt now in saying that I've also put
out a caution nonprofits
are not for profits it is very hard to
measure results in a quantitative way in
a not-for-profit organization and as the
adage goes what you measure gets managed
if you put emphasis on things that are
measurable you actually may drive
organizations to do things that aren't
really adding up to the prize someone
shared with me a little while ago a guy
named Mario molinos who is a very
successful investor venture capitalists
has gotten deeply involved in the art
and science the practice of philanthropy
and as advocated for outcome-based
philanthropy said you know you do need
to be careful though because as we saw
in Vietnam the measure was body count
you can count the number of bodies that
were the result of a battle and what
happened we lost in via the hop we drove
all of the field leadership to think in
terms of how many bodies as we get in
that battle and we're adding a bodies
but at the time we were not we were not
this country was not making progress in
the political environment in the
economic environment the social
environment in Vietnam and it's I had no
hope of winning in Vietnam and the North
Vietnamese we're willing to keep putting
bodies into the body count good example
but a sobering example of measuring the
wrong thing so in a not-for-profit
setting measuring success will require
much more nuanced much more subtle ways
of assessing progress more like
gathering evidence for a legal case than
it is sort of counting something that's
11 caution another caution is that
especially with the emergence of this
new generation of philanthropists who
have a very strong grounding in
entrepreneurially driven enterprises
where they've been inordinately
successful generated a great deal of
wealth frankly figure they kind of know
how to do almost anything and see
themselves as drivers of change good
thing but also needed to help nonprofits
be more sophisticated and I'll tell you
having worked again for a nonprofit
organization the temptation to change
what you're focused on in order to get
that money is too great it's it's it's
overpowering so as I said every year I
worried about raising enough money for
the Nature Conservancy we had a strategy
driven towards our mission we thought it
was well-conceived we would sell that
and often I would encounter very wealthy
people who would say well it that's
interesting that's not what I'm
interested in I'm interested in this
other thing that you know was close
enough like said you know I was just
thinking about that myself I think
what's a really good idea we're ready to
go do that and I will confess that more
than once I was seduced into getting a
big contribution not thinking through
the implications actually ending up
taking on more of a fundraising burden
there was one time when we were working
with caterpillar corporation and they
had a strong interest in watershed
management we didn't have a lot of
experience in the watershed management
we had bought land on River corridors
but watershed management much more
complex undertaking and you know having
to understand users of water and
issues like contamination of water water
rights but caterpillar was really
interested in that they said well they'd
be willing to put up 15 million dollars
and what did I hear 15 million dollars
they said yeah you know we were debts
where we're headed is watershed
management you take all these properties
we bought we're going to figure out it
you know work in the larger watershed
and we got into and realize this is at
least a fifty-million-dollar undertaking
this was on the Upper Mississippi River
that's not a small River and you know
ended up kind of slogging through but
not really living up to what caterpillar
wanted from us so philanthropists as
entrepreneurs need to be very thoughtful
about the pole that they have on
organizations and how they can very
profoundly disorient or distract
organizations from what they say is
their mission and it's very hard in a
non-profit organization where you're
thinking from year to year how you're
going to raise money to have a 10-year
horizon I just very hard to have a three
year horizon then you're going to take
on a project where we're going to stick
with it for three five ten years but I
can only be confident in funding for the
first few years so I think one of the
most important things in in the coming
five years as we see this flourishing of
philanthropy and a very entrepreneurial
II driven philanthropy which i think is
terrific I think it's going to be
imperative that philanthropists
understand the kinds of organizations
that they are supporting their
not-for-profit enterprises and that that
that that connection between the Thunder
and the nonprofit will be exceedingly
important you I'm sure have heard the
term social entrepreneurs it's become I
say quite
active thing for nonprofit foundations
to support and again many cases the
foundations or the funders are people
who have been entrepreneurs in the
for-profit sector again I I believe that
an entrepreneur is an entrepreneur
whatever sector there and they could do
anything an entrepreneur is
characterized again by passionate about
getting something done moves with some
pace and speed willing to take risks has
high comfort for failure that that
applies in any context in any milieu in
any sector the challenge however for a
funder who's interested in supporting
social entrepreneurs is that the notion
of startup capital is very very
different in a not-for-profit setting
that it is in a for-profit setting for
private says you're betting on somebody
who's going to get to a point where they
can spin out a product or a service
something that has demand from buyers
and so the notion of startup is I can
get this I'm going to spin that flywheel
by providing some funding that roughly
same philosophy has applied to social
entrepreneurs I'm going to find people
who have a great idea who show all of
the characteristics and attributes of
being a great entrepreneur they're doing
it for a social cause I'm going to back
that person with startup capital and
what happens is more often than not
those social entrepreneurs have no other
capital coming I know one funder who
puts up $250,000 sort of / entrepreneur
social entrepreneur a five year period
of time with the
expectation that within five years or by
that five-year horizon the social
entrepreneurs will figure out ways of
raising other money they think there
aren't that many other sources of
funding another consequence of that is
it's tending to fragment people who are
really really talented when they should
be aggregating so you find people who
are self identifying a social
entrepreneurs finding and there's more
and more sources of funding for social
entrepreneurs going is it making the
case for me to do this thing when in
fact they should be aggregating
themselves they say why don't we work
together and develop something that can
get to critical mass or can have
sufficient scale to last forever and
I've seen really really fine people move
out of big nonprofit organizations to
become a social entrepreneur because
they like the idea of a start-up when I
would really encourage them to be a sort
of positive deviant within their own
organization I was actually just talking
to a funder the other day and asked if
you ever thought about doing that
finding a big organization whether it's
you know established organization YMCA
nature conservancy care you know that's
got it installed established presence
big resources but frankly probably kind
of plateaued on the yield curve a little
bit you see that with big nonprofits
have you ever thought about funding
people in them to be an entrepreneur as
the term used to be positive deviants
somebody who could you know have the
backing of a funder to drive change in a
big organization and take advantage of
the entrepreneurial characteristics of
some individuals but the resource
capacity of a big organization and I
haven't seen that yet I think that
that's a reach for funding in the
not-for-profit sector so
as a way to maybe sort of wrap up and
then I'd be very interested in your
thoughts and your questions I think that
the world the issues of the we is a
little trite to say the world is so
interconnected now that the problems are
enormously challenging because they are
global in so many ways and yet because
of that they're also actually tractable
and the not-for-profit sector has become
more sophisticated is getting more
sophisticated is better prepared to take
on those tractable problems the same
time there is this enormous infusion of
wealth going into philanthropy and so I
I really do look to the not-for-profit
sector to step out in front and drive
social change the philanthropist
shifting from a sense of charity we
bestow a grant on you we would provide
this this award to you as a charitable
beneficiary as a grant team the
terminology we use is for condescending
moving from being a charity to drivers
of social change working and true
solidarity and collectivity with
organizations they support so that the
combined wealth that is emerging in this
country can have far more influence
collectively than it will separately
with that solidarity with the supported
organizations creates a true sense of
partnership and and not an asymmetrical
relationship of thunder and grantee and
I really do believe that with the
challenges we see the political arena
with what I see is it really an emerging
and and deep-seated understand
in more progressive elements of the
for-profit sector and especially again
from my background and sustainability
we're seeing more and more big global
companies realize that sustainability
has a profound bottom-line influence
we're seeing investors like Jeremy
Grantham from from Boston starting to
point out that if we take the long view
in investing we better be looking at
enterprises that are thinking where
they're going to get their water where
are they going to get their timber
resources where they going to get basic
commodities 10 15 20 years from now so
there's a shift in the wind and
international institutions slow
politically challenged not stepping out
in front that there's a chance now for
the not-for-profit sector the
philanthropic sector working in tandem
with the business community to take on
huge huge social problems each one
bringing something that is unique terms
of its outlook its resources and its
capabilities to address those problems I
really do think we're on the threshold
of a very very exciting new era but all
those sectors will have to step up in
ways they never have before and in ways
that sort of put aside again their
conventional thinking and their
orthodoxies and really try to step out
of the mold and we're we're seeing I
believe some of the first signs of that
so I'm very very very hopeful I see in
this room people who I'm convinced that
in one way or another every one of you
in this room every one of you who's a
student at this school anyone who's
under 25 basically them saying in 10-15
years in one way or another we'll be
working in some enterprise that is
addressing major social change whether
it's a for-profit government or
not-for-profit and I I hope in that 10
or 15 years you will think back so you
know think I'm a quorum
was kind of on the thing is like this a
very different way of society working
together in a vuuka world so the future
is your hands don't it up
see that's how we talk at Berkeley
questions yes the incidence or the lack
of consensus for not an artist to
actually be a lot more progressive for a
lot more efficient actually um I'm just
wondering you know the government really
should be one that should already be
busy a lot of you know a sabbatical it's
a nation of the divisive dividing issues
and so actually the other program that I
end up iTunes adventurer who are
actually in another part of in
complexity we actually are addressing
this issue soon using government as the
12 because there's six hundred billions
in five or six hundred billion dollars
each year as branch money
but not much really knowing you know
what everyone's doing so we're just
thinking you know maybe there should be
some some a percentage of that money
being given to NGOs when expectations
showing precisely how efficient or hung
up to them everyone's doing and giving
each American you know media vultures
that could 50 hours okay to locally both
for which NGOs are demanded drop you can
know what like you know there'd
information with knowing place and
you'll clear so do you think like maybe
there's some possibility of working with
the government monitoring in some way
and also to let this is also a way for a
lot of NGOs to have a free advertising
opportunity and also they work closely
with a population who would they need to
so I hear what you're asking is could
could put on this guy this like this is
a gun could is there some opportunity to
convince the government to create a
weight of understanding the efficiency
and effectiveness of nonprofits so is
that close enough if it's not so good
foundation or more condition can
actually be in the suede could US
government or some other governments to
actually make beagle create some people
ways of actually creating a systematic
the measurement so at the resounding
flip asking government to determine if
nonprofits are efficient is probably not
likely to happen we have a big issue of
whether government is efficient but
you're hitting on a really interesting
point how do you know if a non-profit is
effective and that's are you know it's a
very very hard thing for a donor to
figure out and if you're a modest donor
if you're giving you know fifty dollars
a year you're going to spend a lot of
time trying to figure is this
organization efficient if you're a big
donor like we are we do a lot of due
diligence on the organizations that we
support and we spend a lot of time with
them I have two observations one is as I
was in a perhaps a little elliptical way
suggesting earlier nonprofits are
inherently inefficient it's just they're
just not efficient they're not they're
just not efficient and unfortunately
there are rating services actually
guidestar Charity Navigator the Better
Business Bureau they have rating
services on the efficiency of nonprofit
organizations and typically what they
look at is what's the percentage of the
budget that goes to Gia
to overhead and what goes to program and
so you think well that's probably a
pretty good measure it's not and
nonprofits figure out help frankly how
to game that there are ways you can
classify certain expenditures that look
like program it's not it's not illegal
it's just you know in recruiting members
you put out a lot of marketing materials
is that marketing where is that
advertising I mean is that is we're
promoting your cause another way of
putting it so it's not actively frankly
I don't think any of the rating services
really give you an insight into
efficiency and in any event I don't care
about efficiency we were we support
organizations they're incredibly
inefficient and if I spent a lot of time
trying to help them be efficient it's
beside the point they're incredibly
effective could they do it at less money
probably is it worth the time to try to
make them do that no they're incredibly
effective there are no services that
give you an insight into the
effectiveness of organizations and I
have a guy who just left the Hewlett
Foundation who I have great great
respect for Jacob Harold has just gone
to be the CEO of Charity Navigator and
he to his credit is going to try to
crack that that code how could you
create indices or insights into the
effectiveness of organizations but you
think about again the the structure of a
of how a nonprofit organization gets its
revenue as opposed to a for-profit for
profit has to be constantly providing
something that some of these that one
wants to buy either a good or a service
and they can they can manipulate that
perhaps by advertising still consumers
are making decisions they're putting
money out to get something they don't do
that enterprise gone nonprofit
organization relies on a funder who's
not a beneficiary so funders putting
money into the organization for that
organization
go benefit something nature in the case
of the Nature Conservancy so how do you
go asking nature is in the nature
conservancy so who's better than H
concern is a world while I fun or
Wildlife Conservation International it's
very very very very hard to make that
determination and it requires a lot of
time if you're a donor to tease behind
that I do think one of the things we're
going to see more of and I think Jacob
is at the forefront of that our insights
into the effectiveness of organizations
irrespective of their efficiency yeah
let's look at Valley we recognize this
gift has talent talent so that you have
to pay there are markets for great
talent and I'm just wondering being in a
foundation so you're not having to
constantly have to elevate what are you
talk a little bit about what your
compensation philosophy is and how do
you incentivize besides the great work
people know they're doing right there
people to look at how do you think
they're doing great work too in for
profits how do you how do you
incentivize your your staff boy it's
really question how so how how do we at
the foundation incentivize our staff in
compensation yeah really good question
when I came to the foundation again in
the spirit of Gordon's desire to create
an enterprise that had for the best
characteristics of a business and a
non-profit we had a significant
incentive pay element significant for
I've never seen anything like it in a in
anything other than a for-profit
but it it doesn't work as well
not-for-profit organization because
again you don't you know have a
convention of metrics so if i have a
Salesforce III over time can establish
pretty good understanding of what if
somebody really puts their their heart
into it works really hard what a
benchmark would be you know what I could
expect from an annual sales effort and
you died reward somebody accordingly in
a foundation that's really hard because
are the outcomes that we're trying to
achieve for which we would be rewarded a
consequence of what we did or the
organizations we support so that that's
a huge complication and then it puts it
it creates a distortion around frankly
near-term things and it really
diminishes and it pushed towards
risk-taking and experimentation so we
did away with it I have not seen in any
not-for-profit organization that is not
a foundation but a typical NGO I've not
there are incentive elements to
compensation the nowhere near like what
we had at our foundation what we had our
foundation was nowhere near what you
would have in a in a for-profit in terms
of the the proportion of that annual
incentive compensation on the point of
compensation overall and nonprofit
organizations really really well taken
Heidi I think leading a huge global
enterprise like care is this is is as
challenging as a huge global enterprise
like General Motors more so in many ways
and yet it is the it is the convention
and I don't see this changing at all
that nonprofit compensation
is a fraction of for-profit compensation
and back that the IRS will even look at
whether you know the all nonprofits have
to file a 990 every year it's it's
basically their tax filing that 990 has
also become a disclosure document so
serving two purposes in either one of
which very well but those 99 everybody
looks at the 990s now because I have to
show the top five compensated employees
so it's public information and Congress
keeps an eye on that and the IRS keeps
an eye on that and that gets out into
the donor space I'll share with you when
I was at the nature consider story is a
whole nother our story when I was at the
Nature Conservancy so here I've been in
this I'd grown up with the Nature
Conservancy it became president 2000
when I started our media people told me
the Washington Post is working on an
in-depth story about the nature
conservancy that perfect I come in as
the CEO do an in-depth story i'll be the
Kiro they said need to understand this
is the investigative unit so hot i mean
we're a great organization well long
long long long very complex story in
2000-2001 obviously other things happen
that we invaded Iraq this three-part
series came out in 2003 and it was like
a hit in the solar plexus it was started
above the fold on Sunday which is when
they start all their big stories went
for three days and it led to a
congressional senate finance committee
investigated us i had to do with
transactions we've done with people
who'd been close to the Nature
Conservancy and the assertion was you
know we crossed the line of ethics if
not cross the line of the law but I mean
they and they went into everything
including my compensation and in 2003 i
was paid four hundred twenty thousand
dollars and it's like could you believe
mccormick makes four hundred
and I got letters from irate members
saying I can't believe that this level
of sorry you know you dedicate your
silly corporate influence is terrible
and I just like forty thousand dollars
it's like it's not that much too we've
got 4,500 people spread around the world
and 500 million dollar budget I got a
raise every year there's just a big
backlash to high levels of compensation
not-for-profit someday that may change I
hope it does end of story we were
cleared by the Senate Finance Committee
of you know two years of rigorous
examination as I say that's that's a
whole nother story I put out there only
to tell that story about the scrutiny of
salaries I I I think it's a real
injustice troops and if we're going to
get the caliber of people to go work for
nonprofit who have that entrepreneurial
orientation and and desire look nobody
goes to work for a non-profit for the
money but nobody should really have to
sacrifice their personal lives because
the levels of compensation or so solo
and the stress and I in a nonprofit
organization that's extraordinarily high
i traveled between sixteen seventy
percent of my time when i was present in
the nature conservancy had two little
daughters growing up but you know yet
you're not going to come out and say
that in the light of senate
investigation you kind of hit it thought
you had a sensitive spot Terry yes Julie
are their foundations but there's a
humongous financial incentive against
deviating from the wall street from the
consulting path if your foundation be
willing to invest in 8 a program that
works to get more cops 2 inch from top
universities into the social sector yeah
it's really good quick did you all hear
that would what our foundation would
found our foundation or other foundation
be willing to invest in ways of bringing
people who have the kinds of skills and
talents I was describing I think are
necessary but you know frankly
understandably are attracted to working
for a McKinsey or you know you know in a
corporation or a start-up short answer
is not we haven't yet but I was at
dinner last night with
other foundation presidents and we
talked about this we actually had our
foundation we have six people who came
from consulting backgrounds for whom
were at McKinsey and then these are not
people who were rejected by them but you
know who felt that this was a different
path they wanted to pursue so i'm not
sure that the Conte that that we have to
actually invest in it I just I think
there are other ways to attract people
with those backgrounds into the
not-for-profit sector we are as a
foundation working with some of our
major grantees in helping them build
leadership and those cases were actually
providing support for them to go hire
people who you know frankly wouldn't
take the job but for a little higher
level of compensation so we aren't we
are doing that I think we are out of
time
you